[Music]
and and they won't forget Newsome
anybody use deodorant please that's a
hilarious user name Matt says birds have
been attacking here for three years over
a misunderstanding birds who no birds
held grudges they do they do
producers have my cat just chill outside
no they can sense when your cats like a
like a little [ __ ] cat and they'll just
go after the little [ __ ] cat because my
cat wasn't biscuit though I was it
clearly it was a because [ __ ] up by
itself getting bullied and I was like
well I mean you gotta you gotta fight
that [ __ ] okay the bargains come and
peck the eyes and ninjas fly away like
not if you're fast you could punch them
they were like so he's been he's been
attacked by a murder of crows a murder
it's called a murder it had to beat a
damn black bear tied let's talk about
Ravens Oh wrong bird they're both black
so I was good Devon coals are pretty big
though yeah they are you shocked me oh
it was a hawk once but it was just a
crow I know like there are any ratchet
Birds it would be the crow just they
just show them they just be awesome
Exorcist
they really hurt and they scare all the
other birds away when they land that
liberal Argos yeah I'm out my mom was
always like that was your uncle Bob
right there the crow yeah any time she
saw a crow she's like that's your uncle
Bob reincarnated as a crow yeah really
no remember there was a whole thing with
the movie The Crow was about like a
reincarnated I wasn't yet bird of some
[ __ ] I didn't understand the connection
because my Uncle Bob was gay and died of
AIDS
oh but okay he's a crow now yes name is
Shiva and he should have called him the
rainbow but go ahead I just had to put
that in there the rainbow what no she's
she should have said when you saw it
when she saw a rainbow that's Uncle Bob
see that's good
it's good but uh yeah so this guy here
he said that these crows misinterpreted
a situation like he was in three years
ago so apparently there was this baby
crow and he was trying to save it but it
actually ended up dying in his own in
his hand and so the crows interpreted
that as he killed me like he killed this
baby front of it in the armies busting
budget yeah so four three three years I
didn't know crows live that long
don't they got a flag down south but a
winner no birds do that maybe they're
just 24/7 there it was over he would
come outside they stick to like fight
off the birds every time but he's just
like I wish they understood like I was
trying to save them before all they know
the like he's attacking us with a
[ __ ] stick like Annie backed up with
his car knocked over our birdbath this
guy nothing to know what he's doing
first of all how old do crows even live
yeah three years is a lot generational
curious Nick every time you come out
Maliki just moved that's what I'm saying
but I don't think whatever they said he
did that [ __ ] Charlie Manson there's a
crow here attacking him Oh as they
follow him away - Mouse - oh they always
Mather batata go to work he be at a
staff meeting I know
so he probably has no friends he has
sustained multiple head injuries I see
I'm a different type of person I'm
getting a pistol I'm suing all
blackbirds
if we're enemies then we're enemies oh
yes yeah just kill them all this just
killed again I'd walk around with a
helmet do they bite I bet you they crawl
they go I know they're saying that they
have really sharp beaks sharp beak I bet
I've seen some birds like come swoop
down they're like grab puppies in [ __ ]
like burn actually really there's a lot
of different animals that have rough
seas that we don't know about dolphins
be raping people yeah they're rapists
there are sexual predators kidnap
females female dolphins of other tribes
other dolphin groups they kidnap them
use them as sex slaves and [ __ ]
they're crazy yeah yeah that's the rule
yeah because of their environment it's
not because of their genetics it's my
cousin Bob probably nature versus
nurture dolphin culture we grew up in
like a poor part of the ocean rape
culture so real dolphins gotta get walk
down there man yeah man I gotta switch
to that you gotta cancel ball dolphins
are canceled but it's not all dolphins
okay although anytime I see a dolphin
matru but rape culture is pretty
prevalent in the dolphin society so
anytime I see a person wearing a dolphin
t-shirt I walk up to them and I'm like
shame on you we can't let the minority
of dolphins represent the rest of the
good dog they should stop selling
dolphin t-shirts at aquariums they make
them seem so adorable and cute they are
killers I just see a rapist I don't even
see I did a whole stand-up it went back
when this will always going down when
that first came out the dolphins were
raping and my whole thing was like how
come they never try to approach me
because I'm cute I'm swimming and I
would welcomed it because that's like
that's a story that's a cool inner
dolphin romance and I like to be
submissive but it was awkward it doesn't
happen with wild dolphins you got to go
to those captive dolphins that's when
they [ __ ] you oh really
captive dolphins they [ __ ] to see more
trainers and [ __ ] yeah there's always
videos of like people playing with
dolphins and the dolphin start [ __ ]
them and [ __ ] is when we started pulling
up dolphin dicks because they have a
dick that goes like this and like all of
them they have a dick they have a dick
that grabs you yeah and it will kill you
if they get raped because at first I was
like into it but then I was like oh I
did some more research and they shoot
there come like shoots out like 14 feet
so like it like just smoking explodes
you from this side so it was like oh
never mind dying that way oh my god
dolphin women like to be choked as well
they get soaked with the dick hand no no
that they won one flipper goes around
the neck and then the other it would be
so hard it's actually no it's not funny
actually it's really it's real so really
yeah yeah how do we get to dolphins from
pros you know what I do
I [ __ ] catch one of those crows and
then I would make crow fried chicken
fried crow I would have gotten like the
birds like you know they thought that he
killed it but I got a fake one like yeah
I killed that [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and I'll
be like antagonized like I would piss
them off yeah Birds they come with the
army oh that's what you say until they
maybe you're not scared but if they [ __ ]
on everything your car your home that
was a song this guy is so scared of
birds he went to the news man they used
to use them as torture devices they
would break all the bones in your body
and wrap you into a guoguan will you
still be alive but they let the crows
poke poke poke out your eyes
torture I know it was pretty nice I kind
of left feeling depressed for about -
yeah why go there Jessie it was a family
vacation my family yeah and there was a
lot of loved it
there's a lot of bird ones when they
leave you in a field and like and like
your scarecrow or whatever but they're
like the crows like I like torture would
they do that like other than law or just
way back in the olden day like the
medieval times where they like didn't
have anything to do for fun so they're
just like murder humans and in public
and yeah but in like in torturous ways
they're so crazy I want that's what I
want what do you want
we're like you have to sit on the
pyramid and whatever orifice that is a
you know you're back home
there's a pyramid and you sit on it and
then it starts from your butthole and it
splits you in half the horse one when
you put someone in the middle you tie
one horse that's what you want to do
right apparently not to me oh okay well
thank you that's what I've been waiting
for that snow for Jamali of my country
okay time ago they did that to quit it
could be like minor infractions even
they don't know for me it's got to be
serious crimes like stealing chips
because we all love chips you shouldn't
steal chips yeah serious cause Mike's
doing tips kid touches touches kid
touches and in the the the the better
the chips brand like [ __ ] if it's
flamin hot cheetos the harsh of the
crime you still there - dang dude
nothing has changed because the kingdom
of Jamal has no Queen now but it's
actually gotten worse yeah the king is
that yeah yeah no we're celebrating by
we're celebrating the divorce by burning
a phallic mm note 20,000 molesters and
pedophiles 20,000 monsters madness 13
days of course that means here - idea
that's
we're going to buy them from other
countries oh we ran out yeah yeah a
little coffee ball you over here now
free Mallya America I'm sure you have
ten thousand-plus
molesters and para fires you could hook
up you're like yeah we don't need them
and then we'll bring them on and then
it's like we have laws but we don't
really like them that much anyway so
here's the problem with human rights
right it only applies to humans right
they're not human they're monster genius
so that's why it works let your
imagination run 100 mill you move when I
punch that [ __ ] in the face bird I
swear no he did he really did well then
he moves like a big prehistoric birds
they're like [ __ ] six feet tall and
yeah I was wearing a shiny watch and I
guess they they liked that [ __ ] so he
like bit me on the arm and I reflexively
like punched him in the head just like
you try to rob birds out of robbed you
for your watch he was like he bit me on
the arm yeah and then he immediately
just goes circling this I don't know
what to do [ __ ] yeah he stole that was
just a general reaction I love animals
but I will defend myself me too if I go
to Indonesia the monkey try to steal my
cell phone I'm punching that [ __ ]
monkey
I support monkey punches
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]